Vsauce Kevin here I'm gonna play a song
I wrote just for you
ready here we go
wait is this a song is a drill music
actually let's back up a second like all
the way back let's put you back in the
womb
[Music]
[Music]
ah you've been born
welcome to humanity and your brain has
gifted you with musicality while music
is a social and cultural construct
meaning that it's something we create
ourselves musicality describes the
mental processes that underlie musical
behavior and perception your brain is
trained to respond to emotional and
international aspects of the human voice
an important feature of human biology
despite only an eight percent body mass
difference adult males have a voice
about 50 percent deeper than females
your brain adapts to processing
information being delivered at different
pitches but studies show Tweety Bird and
the rest of the animal kingdom have
trouble with this relative pitch allows
you to recognize relationships between
notes to transpose the same tune in a
different key so if you hear mary had a
little lamb sung in a high pitch by
Mickey Mouse or in a low pitch by Darth
Vader
you'll still recognize that it's mary
had a little lamb Tweety Bird and
Curious George would think they were
completely different songs
okay humans notice the nuance of pitch
but what happens when you lose the sense
of hearing or never had it in the first
place the brains of the deaf and hard of
hearing can rewire to feel music rather
than hear it the information is
processed in the brain similarly to how
others hear sound even without the
ability to hear music finds its way into
our bodies and for some people that
experience results in feeling an
estimated 4% of humans lack musicality a
museu is an inability to recognize pitch
changes and can include problems with
musical recognition and memory this
causes difficulty understanding not only
the emotion of music but also nuances of
line
which like being able to distinguish the
pitch change that differentiates
statements from questions this is a
statement this is a question and they're
short term pitch sequence memory
deficiency prevents a musics from
forming the story of music in their
minds to remember the pitches they've
heard to anticipate their repetition and
to be aroused by their changes yet some
can process pitch and still not derive
any gratification from music most people
physiologically react to pleasurable
music with higher skin conductance and
heart rate but researchers found that
people with musical anhedonia showed no
relationship between musical enjoyment
and a physiological response while music
and give most people chills a dopamine
increase in the nucleus accumbens music
to them as just kind of friend-zoned
these musical disorders show us that
music isn't just about processing sound
it's about using that sound to
understand the thoughts and feelings of
others an education that begins after
the doctor slaps your tiny butt cheeks
and your mom starts babbling in your
crying cute little infant face baby talk
or mother ease is a type of speech
marked by exaggerated pitch our earliest
understanding of verbal communication
involves prosody the rhythmic patterns
of stress and intonation and language
mama
Dada Dada without that pitch change it
sounds emotionless robotic and kind of
creepy
mama studies show babies pay more
attention when they hear exaggerated
pitch length and timbre their brains
love the excitement of surprises pitch
can matter a lot to meaning it's so
important in Mandarin Chinese that the
same word can have completely different
meanings based on how you say it ma can
mean mother scold hemp or horse before
kids learn syntax they may learn the
building blocks of language through the
alphabet song which comes from a French
folk song Mozart popularized in twelve
variations on a vous des rechts mem all
later becoming baa baa black sheep and
twinkle twinkle little star it's a
popular tune not only does musicality
help with language and predates the
alphabet song musicality predates the
alphabet itself and all written language
by a lot middle aged bards Beethoven and
Beyonce didn't invent musical
communication before our ancestors
developed writing values memories and
customs were conveyed through song
sacred song cycles honored the gods
passed down histories and were the
essential medium of memory
ethnomusicologist Jon blacking suggests
singing and dancing preceded Homo
sapiens
by several hundred thousand years Caves
are full of acoustic reverberations like
your shower that must have made cavemen
ugh feel like Pavarotti
but ugh couldn't just make noise of
needed notes
unlike noise which features sharp
erratic waveforms notes are repeating
ripple patterns of sound a hammer
hitting a nail creates an irregular
ripple of air pressure while a flute can
create a consistent ripple that repeats
over and over an easy way to produce
notes is with a column flutes and
clarinets vibrate the air within a
column strings are columns that can
vibrate pressing a tightly stretched
string against the neck of an instrument
shortens its
length which alters its vibration and
pitch the consistent whirring of a
spinning drill produces a musical note
as sustaining it is a form of drone
music controlling notes and creating
music make audible order out of nature's
chaos darkness is scary and overwhelming
because you can't see what danger may be
lurking but you can renew your comfort
with light
silence reflects the absence of life we
often say it's dead quiet but you can
fight back with sound and in that battle
you form a relationship with people
you'll never meet as the language of
emotion and physiological arousal music
is a fundamental method of connecting
you to others preliterate tribes use
music to unify the group in times of
danger songs are used in religious
services to call us the group in music
collaborating becomes proof that the sum
can be greater than its individual parts
music welds you together with others at
parties clubs weddings work and even
funerals concerts are a celebration of
collective cultural unity in movies
music reinforces and heightens the
emotion of the scene national anthems
reflect the history values and dreams of
entire countries made up of millions of
people past present and future music
unites what you see what you hear what
you think and what you feel
literally sound physically touches you
my voice is touching your eardrums and
causing them to go in and out I'm moving
part of you with every word music is so
intrinsically tied to our motor systems
that children have difficulty remaining
still when singing a study of musics
effects on exercise showed cyclists who
synchronize their movements with music
required 7% less oxygen than those who
didn't the riff
in tempo of music and unlock the body
for sufferers of Parkinson's disease
bring them to move despite the disease
freezing their movements it's the
soundtrack to our motion and behavior
consciously and subconsciously
background music in stores influences
shoppers to stay longer and buy more if
classical music is playing in a liquor
store you're more likely to buy more
expensive wine if French music is
playing err more likely to buy French
wine music drives cultural behaviors and
connects us to time which is why songs
arouse a strong sense of nostalgia your
head is like a jukebox with eyeballs the
songs you know become part of your
mental catalogue and you're able to
recall them with incredible accuracy ear
worms are those catchy bits of music
that repeat over and over sometimes
called involuntary musical imagery it's
also possible to remember almost nothing
but music in his book music Ophelia
Oliver Sacks tells the tale of former
renowned musician and conductor Clive
wearing who after a brain infection had
virtually his entire memory erased
retrograde amnesia left him unable to
recall his past and anterograde amnesia
allows his short-term memory to last
only up to 30 seconds after every
handful of blinks Clive's eyes open to a
brand new world his subsequent
loneliness confusion and constant fear
left him feeling robbed of consciousness
he says it's like being dead
in an attempt to regain control of his
life he started keeping a journal but
the entries amounted to simply repeating
the same sentiment and crossing out the
previous one this time properly awake
this time finally awake
this time completely awake
one of Clive's only portals back to his
life is his wife Deborah to him her
visits to the facility where he lives
are a miracle resulting in sobbing and
clinging to her presence but within
minutes of her departure he leaves
messages for her saying please come and
see me darling it's been ages since I've
seen you please fly here at the speed of
light she would have had to travel at
the speed of light to get there before
Clive forgot that he needed to see her
the only other gateway to himself the
only thing that holds him in the state
of being Clive is music he plays the
piano sings and learns new songs while
eating a chocolate bar he is constantly
surprised by how the bar is changing
because he forgets that he's been eating
it but as he plays music his symptoms
are suspended temporarily music allows a
precious moment in which Clive wearing
is Clive wearing again
the momentum of the music briefly keeps
him afloat before sinking back down into
that lost place through music he stays
awake completely awake until the song is
over
in 1886 painting by George Frederick
Watts depicts hope as a blindfolded
woman sitting on the globe clutching a
broken harp and desperately listening to
the sound of a single frail string the
only one that remains
as long as you have music and the
ability to embrace meaning from the
sounds around you you cannot be alone
that is hope and as always thanks for
watching
[Music]
really